[Musique]
toute sensibilité avec les oreilles ou les
lèvres qui
claquent d'
accord on évitera ça pour celle-ci quand
on dit qu'on veut faire du porno différemment
le cœur de ça commence par la façon dont on se
dirige elle a tant fait dans le
monde du consentement  en mettant les
interprètes à l'aise, c'est ainsi que le porno
devrait être action
[Musique]
nous l'avons fait vous l'avez fait
j'ai eu un accès exclusif dans les coulisses
d'un plateau porno pour ce que je voulais
comprendre, c'est comment cette industrie se
réinvente alors j'ai rencontré le
réalisateur  brie moulins une vétéran de l'industrie
qui dit qu'elle essaie de mettre le consentement
au cœur de son travail
[Music]
utilisons notre temps maintenant
pour passer en revue ce que l'ordre du jour
va être pour aujourd'hui en termes de choses que
nous devons tourner nous '  nous allons commencer
par
nous allons avoir kenneth et le sexe anal
comme notre premier objectif aujourd'hui
afin que kenneth puisse manger et se détendre et
tout cela
pour nous le consentement n'est pas quelque chose qui est
une liste de contrôle ou est un élément d'action à faire
le jour de euh pour nous c'est réel  ly est en
quelque sorte le système nerveux central de l'ensemble de notre
processus de production, donc si je vais
réserver un talent pour un
projet où le consentement commence, ils doivent
savoir quel est le scénario,
ils ne se présentent jamais sur le plateau sans une
visibilité complète sur ce qu'ils  se présentent sur le
plateau pour faire avec qui ils se présentent sur le plateau
et qu'ils sont à l'aise
avec ce choix qui va être le
prochain coup, mais
oui, ils sont bons
comme beaucoup dans le secteur du divertissement que
l'industrie du porno avait  son propre moment de prise en
compte avec de nombreux interprètes
dénonçant les abus et exprimant des critiques
sur leurs conditions de travail et ces
critiques continuent d'exister
moulin dit que sa première priorité est d'apporter le
consentement et la transparence à l'ensemble mais
elle pense aussi que ses histoires peuvent
cheval de Troie un plus sain  approche du sexe
qui ne sait pas quel œil oh trop ringard
ça commence dans les histoires que nous
racontons nous cherchons toujours à nous
assurer qu'il y a
une conséquence verbale visuelle vraiment claire  Dans chaque histoire,
il y a quelque chose dont je voulais en quelque sorte
vous parler
depuis un petit
moment maintenant, j'essayais de me sortir d'
être un acteur et
réalisateur adulte et de regarder la perception
de quelqu'un dans une chose basée sur la réalité
qui n'est jamais  été dans des situations où un
pourcentage important de couples ne savent pas
comment communiquer correctement ou
ne communiquent pas correctement, je suis vraiment
fier de ce que nous avons pu accomplir au
cours des derniers jours, car
cela ne se fait pas, vous le savez
n'est-ce pas simplement fait d'une manière
qui raconte une histoire de manière cinématographique mais
aussi cette belle histoire de
sexe consensuel mais aussi d'une manière où
c'est juste que c'est juste la beauté de la vie
et les bons et les mauvais d'une
relation  et toutes ces différentes
couches de personnages,
j'ai été
vraiment curieux de
faire de l'anal
avec toi
et je ne veux pas que tu me regardes
comme si j'étais sale ou quelque chose comme ça
mais
aucun jugement
qu'elle l'ait fait  beaucoup  dans le monde du
consentement et de mettre les artistes à l'
aise
et de se concentrer vraiment sur nos besoins,
ce qui, quand je suis entré pour la première fois,
ils étaient depuis environ huit ans,
n'était pas toujours le cas, ils ne se
souciaient pas nécessairement de savoir
si c'était quelqu'un  vous avez aimé ou si c'était
une situation avec laquelle vous étiez nécessairement à l'
aise, c'était ce qui
allait être de bonnes notes, vous savez et des
choses comme ça, mais je me sens comme dans l'
industrie aujourd'hui avec des plates-formes telles que
uniquement des fourgonnettes et un endroit pour nous donner
notre propre point de vente euh
cela nous a vraiment donné un endroit où aller hé
nous voulons être mieux traités nous ne
comptons plus sur vous et donc regarder cette
industrie évoluer
vers cet endroit consensuel incroyable
j'aime vraiment la direction que cette
industrie va prendre le correcteur  je
vais nettoyer cette zone puis je vais
kenna et damon comme vous pouvez le voir damon n'a
rien répertorié mais nous verrons dans notre
scan de la tête aux pieds
et avec kenna elle a indiqué ne pas
cracher dans la bouche ou sur le visage mais nous allons
aussi  bien sûr, faites également
un scan complet de la tête aux pieds avec elle,
il est également très important de découvrir ce
qu'ils apprécient
réellement et comment nous pouvons intégrer cela dans
la scène et dans les personnages,
car cela va améliorer la
scène de sexe.
est généralement quelque chose de plus agréable à
regarder qu'une simple performance pure, donc
avant que vous sachiez que nous tournons tout ce qui
se passe dans un espace intime,
nous appelons toujours une pause dans notre journée et
avons ce que nous appelons une réunion de toutes les mains
et c'est là que nous nous réunissons non seulement  le
casting mais aussi l'équipe
parce qu'il est de notre
responsabilité collective de nous assurer que ce dont nous
discutons est respecté tout au
long du tournage du sexe lui-même d'
accord, nous avons tout
le monde autour de la table
cool ce qui nous importe plus que
toute autre chose, c'est ce
que tout le monde ressent
le jour de ce qu'ils ressentent après l'
impression que nous laissons et sachant que
nous ne faisons pas seulement du
grand art vraiment cool, mais nous prenons également
soin les uns des autres et nous '  Je m'assure
que c'est un espace sûr quand nous disons que nous
voulons faire du porno différemment, le cœur de
cela commence par la façon dont nous gérons nos sets
et que si je peux faire quelque chose dans le
reste de ma carrière, c'est pour essayer de
m'assurer que ça colle plus  qu'autre chose,
ce n'est pas une scène où l'un de vous
va dégrader l'autre ou vous
savez nécessairement utiliser un
langage désobligeant ce n'est pas comme
mettre mon pied sur votre visage vous savez que vous êtes une
[ __ ] de type scène d'horreur mais de la
même manière une chose  vous n'aviez pas sur
votre liste de non kenna était comme ne pas cracher sur
le visage ou dans la bouche et encore une fois je
ne peux pas imaginer que bryce va le
personnage bryce va faire ça mais
vraiment important d'exprimer que nous
n'allons pas faire  que euh comment pensons-nous
où nous aurons beaucoup de lubrifiant
et tout ce qui est disponible êtes-vous à l'
aise avec la salive si elle est utilisée pour le
lubrifiant ou sur toute autre partie du corps
absolument
et damon j'ai remarqué que vous n'aviez rien mis
directement  pour vous
sur votre liste pour n  ose
j'ai l'impression que nous avons suffisamment travaillé ensemble
pour le porter
ouais
ouais elle sait est-ce que tu aimes ça quoi que ce
soit dans ta tête et
j'aime mon cou mon cou et mes mamelons
énervés et léchés et
je me fais des conneries  vraiment en ce moment
euh embrasser
ouais ils sont toujours en train de s'embrasser est-ce
qu'il y a une façon dont tu aimes être
attrapé j'aime être
pressé
comme manipulé giflant d'
accord nous éviterons cela pour celui-ci
peut-être comme un léger étouffement léger ouais
ouais léger étouffement  ce que la meilleure
chose que nous puissions faire est simplement d'apporter le
consentement éclairé dans la scène également, donc
si vous le ressentez sur le moment et
que mila et bryce se sentent sur le
moment, apportez simplement le consentement dans la
scène où vous savez demander  pour et puis
votre partenaire sait que c'est bien je ne vois pas
forcément que c'est le moment où
mila et bryce décident de faire des trucs anaux
sur bryce
mais aussi pour préciser s'il y a quelque chose
mais s'il y a quelque
chose que vous appréciez vraiment comme vous  sachez
bien sûr, faisons ressortir cela
peut-être que je devrais l'essayer oui ça
devient une scène d'ancrage pour la partie aussi
peut-être que je devrais essayer hey mec c'est comme l'
un des fantasmes numéro un que les
gars ont mais euh mais pas nécessairement dans
l'épisode d'aujourd'hui euh communication  est la
clé de l'histoire à droite un couple qui
essaie de poser l'un pour l'autre, ils se
rendent compte qu'ils devraient simplement parler
pour que la communication de ces enregistrements en
cours de route soit un si bel
exemple que nous pouvons partager avec les
gens qui regardent,
donc j'encourage vraiment  qu'historiquement,
il y a eu la perception dans notre
industrie de
ne pas être
difficile à traverser la scène, je veux que
vous sachiez qu'il n'y a
jamais de mauvaise raison de dire une pause ou de couper d'
accord, alors j'ai besoin d'un moment  j'ai besoin d'un
verre d'eau cette position semble bizarre
il n'y a pas de mauvaise raison je veux que ce
soit l'espace le plus sûr d'accord tout le monde
préparons-nous à le faire neil a commencé
ses pourparlers de consentement en 2019 dans la
main de tous  s réunion en 2021, donc c'est vraiment
assez nouveau dans l'industrie et la dernière
partie du système est une conversation avec l'
agent de liaison des talents après avoir joué,
les acteurs ont accès à un
agent de liaison des talents pour leur parler de leur
expérience sur un plateau négatif ou positif
j'aime mon partenaire de scène pour aujourd'hui et
je suis très excité de vivre quelque chose d'
aussi intime que l'anal pour la première fois
avec eux
euh si nerveux excité
pour vous deux votre seul
point de référence sont les stars du porno ayant des relations sexuelles anales et
vous essayez de  agir comme si c'était comme si
je m'ouvrais et tout allait bien
mais tu es aussi dégoûté cela peut
être quand tu es comme ça va comme
genre de vérification et tu peux être comme
honnêtement je ne sais pas quoi
je fais honnêtement j'essaie tellement d'être sexy
je ne sais pas comment les filles font toutes les
vidéos
j'ai regardé une triple pénétration anale et
je ne pense pas que je suis cette fille
J'essaie d'être cette fille ouais
ne le refaites pas ouais l'
air mal à l'aise d'accord toutes les
choses qu'on vous a appris à ne pas faire
cependant
[Musique]
dans le monde de la production pour adultes,
nous opérons évidemment à une
échelle bien plus petite que les productions grand public
souvent vous êtes vous  vous envisagez de
produire une fonctionnalité complète de
40 à 60 minutes
en une seule journée de production
si vous avez de la chance, vous savez à nouveau si vous
avez le budget pour le faire,
combien de temps suis-je ici avant qu'elle n'arrive,
nous n'y allons pas  pour vous dire
jusqu'à ce que nous ressentions votre maladresse et votre
action, je dirai toujours à mes acteurs de
ne pas agir, soyez simplement
si vous étiez à ce moment-là dans cet
espace de tête avec tout ce contexte,
que feriez-vous que diriez-vous que
feriez-vous  pensez d'accord, apportons cela
, utilisons
vos mots réels et vos
sentiments réels ce qu'il y a dans la boîte,
nous sous-estimons toujours le talent qui
existe dans notre côté du divertissement,
mais nous avons certains des acteurs les plus incroyables
que vous ayez jamais vus qui sont
capables  dans un d  ay de créer ces
personnages dans ces situations
et tout le monde est prêt ouais et les
gens d'action qui sont prêts à regarder et à payer
pour du porno narratif ils veulent toute l'
histoire et j'ai joué john travolta et
la fièvre du samedi soir j'ai fait toutes ces
parodies folles j'étais harry potter
en fait, ça s'appelait harry twatter
c'était ridicule quand je joue un
personnage, le plus difficile est qu'une fois que vous avez
réellement une connexion physique, vous
restez dans le personnage que vous êtes réellement
pendant que vous avez des relations sexuelles, continuez pendant
20 secondes mais je te veux  pour insérer vos
doigts comme ils sont en ce moment, puis
dire quelque chose à propos de je vais jouer avec
votre chatte ou quelque chose pendant que cela se
produit,
coupez
génial d'accord, nous avons terminé la
première séquence,
vous allez bien, je sais que c'est un
peu maladroit  dans le processus, ouais,
laissez-moi vous poser une question, préférez-vous les
parcourir tous, puis
revenir ou préférez-vous le faire par poste
, faisons le
mish, puis faites ce que vous voulez.  plans de montage
et qu'est-ce que nous faisons pour la première fois alors nous
devons aller très lentement vraiment ça
va ralentir le rythme de l'escargot ouais ouais
exactement ouais parce que je suis à mi-coup, donc de façon
réaliste, je n'aurais pas trop
fait d'
accord alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait  je suis parti pour faire ici
un chien
ouais
et en ce moment mon frère tu es des pros à ce
stade donc je veux que tu baises
comme pas plus comme ça nous avons dépassé le
seuil et en quelque sorte euh lui parler par
son visage avant de faire le  insérez
comment vous allez êtes-vous prêt êtes-vous
prêt pour comme vraiment avoir un peu
presque comme un moment les uns avec les autres
allons chercher l'or
dans notre coin tranquille en tant que créateurs de
beaucoup de fantasmes que les gens regardent
sur le sexe  pour moi, je vois une si belle
opportunité d'utiliser cela pour ne pas être une
éducation sexuelle parce que je ne pense pas que nous
devrions être les éducateurs sexuels par défaut, mais
nous sommes certainement des influenceurs dans cet
espace et nous pouvons influencer positivement en
plus de fournir un excellent
divertissement
[Applaudissements  ]
[Musique] d'
accord
[Musique]
donc  euh
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec tous ceux qui
comprennent bien nous sommes un travail incroyable les
gars
comme ça a l'air [ __ ] de magnifique
pas de conneries vous deux êtes incroyables
merci pour la patience
j'ai l'impression que j'aimerais continuer à
vous complimenter mais je  je pense
que tu devrais savoir
ce que tu es
tu sais ce que tu es
vous êtes des enfants fous
merci
beaucoup c'était incroyable j'aime les gens avec
qui je travaille et de voir les gens être
fiers de leur travail et de voir les gens
s'embrasser  les uns les autres et pleurant parce
qu'ils sont si fiers et prennent ce qu'ils ont
tourné et le mettent dans leurs bobines grand public
c'est au moins pourquoi je suis ici
c'est pourquoi je le fais à ce
stade c'est toujours un plaisir de travailler  avec
puis-je obtenir une photo de vous de nous
c'est comme ça que nous faisons un porno qui est si
bon que cela commence par nous être fiers de
ce que nous faisons en traitant notre médium
avec respect
et en montrant au monde à travers ce que nous faisons
que vous connaissez le  le mot p n'est pas une
chose négative que nous voulons  déstigmatiser
notre industrie nous voulons humaniser notre
industrie
et cela commence par nous accepter
vous